our subject for this evening
re-writing the script re-writing
the script is our subject for this
evening
and god spake all these words saying
i am the lord thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt
out of the house of bondage thou shalt
have
no other gods before me thou shalt not
make unto thee
any grievan image or any likeness of
anything
that is in heaven above or that is in
the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them for i the lord thy god
am a jealous god visiting the iniquity
of the fathers upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of
them that hate me
ensuring mercy unto thousands of them
that love me
and keep my commandments thou shalt not
take the name of the lord thy god in
vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter
thy man's servant nor thy maidservant
nor thy cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy
gates for in six days the lord made
heaven and earth the sea and all that in
them
is and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it honor thy father
and thy mother that thy days may be long
upon the land which the law thy god
giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery
thou shalt not steal thou shalt not bear
a false witness against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house thou
shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife nor
his manservant
nor his maidservant nor his orks
nor his ass nor anything
that is thy neighbors i am grateful to
god for this privilege
to bring to you the words of life
without the words of life we have no
hope
god created the universe using the word
god healed using the word god
raised the dead using the word
god cast out evil spirits using the word
god functions through his word and for
me
it is a tremendously high honor to be
hand
picked by god to deliver the words of
life to you tonight
wherever you are god bless you if
there's anyone listening right now
you are not a seventh-day adventist we
are especially delighted that you have
joined us
and may the lord bless you with his
choices blessings and place a hedge of
protection
around your family we are always
delighted to have
guests non-seventh-day adventists tune
in
to our services or attend our church
services
our subject for this evening re-writing
the script
re-writing the script is our subject
for this evening before i plunge
into that subject i'll ask you to do
three little favors for me
favor number one i want you to maintain
reverence wherever you are it is of
little
significance or consequence whether you
worship in the backside of a mountain or
desert
like moses at the burning bush or in the
temple of solomon
god's holiness does not change
so even though you are listening in the
comfort of your home wherever you are
preserve holiness and reverence i should
say and this will please god very much
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth this
request
is based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his
hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth
this text teaches me very powerfully how
god
works the divine works with the human
to provide or to bring about miracles
through the word of god
here's what i mean listen to the verse
again jeremiah 1 verse 9
then the lord that's divine put forth
his hand
that's divine and touch my mouth that's
human
and the lord divine said unto me this
i divine have put my words divine
in thy mouth human and so i want god's
divine words placed
in my human mouth i also think of the
words of david in 2nd samuel
chapter 23 verse 2 where he said the
spirit of
god spake by me and his word
was in my tongue i want god's words
in my mouth in my tongue in my heart
and favor number three i want you to
think
as you listen thinking is not as
automatic as some of us may suspect
many people come to church and they sit
without much
mental activity i was in a certain
country several years ago
i was staying at a hotel i spoke to one
of the workers a young lady
and i asked her are you a christian she
said yes do you go to church
yes do you read the bible no
so i said why not she said my pastor
reads it for me
and i pleaded with her don't let anyone
read the bible for you read the bible
for yourself
i don't know how far my counsel went but
i'm saying to you
you must think the word of god is for
you
as an individual let me say that again
i'll say differently
when reading the word of god read it as
if
god is speaking to you first peter
chapter 5
verse 8 casting all your cares upon him
for he careth for you that was written
for you not the person sitting next to
you it was written for you
and you must personalize the bible
when paul writes in philippians 4 13 i
can do all things
through christ which strengtheneth me
that verse was written for the man
listening to me struggling with smoking
that verse was written for the lady
struggling with shopping until she drops
you are able the bible says to gain that
victory
of this victory through jesus christ
always read the bible as god's
personal message to you my favorite
writer outside of the bible ellen white
she writes these words in mind character
and personality
volume 2 page 4 23 paragraph 2
the gospel deals with individuals
you must believe for yourself you must
repent for yourself
is this must be done individually
as one of our speakers said character is
not transferable
and the decisions for christ cannot be
made by proxy
in other words i cannot accept jesus for
you
and so as you listen think for
yourselves
and the spirit of god will bless your
thinking let us pray
our father and our god as we deliver the
words of life
take possession of my mind and my
apparatus of speech
use media god as an instrument in the
hands of a musician
and let the music of the gospel reach
every listening heart
where have offended you forgive me grant
me grace
grant me boldness de god but also grant
me compassion as i speak
for i too am a sinner bless all those
listening father
you know their joys and their sorrows
their aches and their pains
attend to them their god on a very
personal level
as your servant says in steps to christ
page 100 paragraph 1
the relation between christ and each
soul are as distinct and full
as though there were not another soul
upon the earth to share his watch care
not another soul for whom he gave his
beloved son this is how you father
deal with those who come to you and so
bless us personally
i commit this service to your glory
bless us with truth
as we honor your holy name in jesus name
we pray
amen our subject rewriting the script
let's find out something about god
you know hebrews says without faith it
is impossible to please him
for he that cometh unto god must
believe that he is
first then he is a rewarder of them that
diligently seek him
we must believe that god is
let's take a look at god job chapter 42
reading verses 1 and 2. the book of job
chapter 42 the last chapter of that book
reading verses 1
and 2 our subject re-writing the script
and i read from the king james version
of the bible
the bible says then job answered the
lord and said
i know that thou canst do everything
and that no thought can be withholding
from thee
job says to god i know you can do
everything
anything you choose no thought no plan
no proposition devised by a created
being
can be hidden from god or can be
executed without god's command or
permission so job says
i know that thou canst do
everything and that no thought can be
withholding
from thee let us go
to jeremiah 27.
jeremiah 27 we read
verse 5 god sent a message
to the israelites or the jews via
jeremiah
and his message was warning the jews to
accept
the sovereignty to accept the rulership
of nebuchadnezzar by the way that
message went to the
the moabites the ammonites those entire
those in zidane
all the surrounding nations the message
was for them put your neck
under the yoke of nebuchadnezzar
now god is expressing his sovereignty in
verse 5
of jeremiah 27 the bible said i
have made the earth the man
and the beasts that are upon the ground
by my great power
and by my outstretched arm and have
given it
unto whom it seemed meet unto me
let's read that verse again the last
part i'll read the whole verse
i have made the earth says god
in other words i decide who exercises
power
and who doesn't i have made the earth
jeremiah 27
5 the man and the beast that are upon
the ground
god could have said the trees and the
flowers and the fish but
he lets us know all of creation is his
work
and by my great power and by my
outstretched arm
our straight arm is a divine will of god
which no one can contradict
no one can resist when god decides to do
something no one can stop him
isaiah 14 27 for the lord of god the
lord of hosts have purposed
and who shall disall it and his hand is
stretched out
who can turn it back the stretched out
arm of god
is god executing his sovereign will no
one
can change that and so we go back to
jeremiah 27
5 as we're learning something about god
i have made the earth the man and the
beast
that are upon the ground by my great
power
and by my outstretched arm and have
given it unto whom
it seemed meat unto me
the king james language i love it
sometimes it's a little
strange and it's sounding god is saying
i made the earth
i decide who exercises power and who
doesn't and where
and when and how long
that's the sovereignty of god no one
tells god what to do god does as he
wills
psalm 115 reading from verse 1
not unto us o lord not unto us but unto
thy name give glory
for thy mercy and for thy true sin
wherefore shall the heathen say
where is now their god but our god is in
the heavens
he hath done whatsoever he have pleased
understand this bible teaching god
is sovereign
as a matter of fact this was lucifer's
problem he wanted to be part of that
sovereign will so he can decide with god
and he was not allowed
this is a privilege for christ who is
equal with the father
and so he sulked got angry and we know
the disastrous results
god is sovereign
let's go to acts 17. i want this to be
biblical not my opinion
in prophets and kings page 6 26 ella
white writes
the words of the bible and the bible
alone should be heard from the pulpit
acts 17 reading from verse 22
our subject rewriting the script let me
pray again father
as i continue tighten your grip on my
mind my mouth my heart i pray
in jesus name amen acts 17
reading from verse 22 paul stood in the
midst of mars hill and said
ye men of athens i perceive that in all
things you're too superstitious
for as i passed by and beheld your
devotions i
found an altar with this inscription to
the unknown
god whom therefore ye ignorantly
worshiped
him declare i unto you god that made the
world on
all things therein seeing that he is
lord of heaven and earth
dwelleth not in temples made with hands
neither is worship with men's hands as
though he needed
anything seeing he giveth to all life
and breath and all things the bible is
very clear god does not
need anything from me god is
self-existent
god existed before any created being was
made
neither is worship with man's hands as
though he
needed anything seeing he giveth to all
life and breath and all things
god is sovereign
it's a feature of divinity
you and i cannot tell god what to do
i've often had to talk to people who are
upset with god because he did not do
what they said
you cannot command god you cannot
instruct
god god commands us
god instructs us and it must be a
foundational
view of god that he is sovereign
and he does what pleases him he does
what he wants to do
let me add something to the sovereignty
of god
everything god does is for his glory
comfort and courage page 21 paragraph 5
god created man
for his own glory but isaiah 43 verse 7
says the same thing
i have created him for my
glory psalm 19 verse 1 the heavens
declare the glory of god
all the heavens declare the glory of god
isaiah 6
3 the whole earth is full of his glory
heaven and earth were created to reflect
the glory of god mankind was made
to reflect the glory of god meaning we
were made for god
god wasn't made for us god is not made
god is a maker
god is not made let me stress again god
is a
sovereign god no one tells him what to
do
three god makes things
for his glory
on the sixth day of creation genesis 1
verse 26
and god said let us make man in our
image
after our likeness that includes for our
glory let
us make man in our image after
our likeness
god is suffering whatever god acts he
acts
for his glory let me tell you something
else
about god in the context of the plan of
salvation
in the book desire of ages page 19
paragraph two
the servant of the lord writes these
astonishing words
both the redeemed and the unfallen
beings
will find in the cross of christ their
science
and their song listen again
both the redeemed that's you and me
and the unfallen beings those who live
on worlds where people never sinned
will find in the cross of christ
their science and their song meaning
that what
christ accomplished on this earth was
not just for this earth
we're learning about god the plan of the
gospel was not simply
to deliver this atom of a world as
elowhite refers to this world an atom of
a world
it had universal consequences
both the redeemed and the unfallen
beings
will find in the cross of christ their
science and their song
the gospel calvary was for the universe
not just for this world the power of
calvary
that keeps me from sin in michigan or
fresno
keeps beings from sin throughout the
universe what keeps from sin on earth
keeps from sin anywhere else what
protects on earth
protects everywhere else put very simply
calvary's cross
protects the entire universe god is
sovereign
god acts for his glory and the plan of
salvation
was not just for this earth it was for
the universe
having said that let's look at
sovereignty
at a lower level let's go to uh
daniel chapter five we'll read 18
and 19. we're looking at sovereignty
at the lower level our subject rewriting
the script
i'll pray again dear god direct my mind
speak literally through me i pray and
give me simple language
in jesus name amen
daniel 5 reading from verse 18 daniel
has been summoned by belteshazza to
explain the handwriting on the wall
before daniel explains the details of
the handwriting
he delivers a discourse to baltism
verse 18 of daniel 5
o thou king the most high god gave to
nebuchadnezzar thy father
a kingdom majesty and glory
and honor and for the majesty which he
gave him
all people nations and languages
trembled and feared before him now we're
talking about
sovereignty at the lower level we looked
at god being sovereign
we're looking at sovereignty at the
lower and restricted level
all people nations and languages tremble
and feared before him that's
nebuchadnezzar
now listen carefully daniel 5 19
whom he would he slew
whom he would he kept alive
whom he would he set up whom he would
he put down
that was nebuchadnezzar he was a
sovereign ruler we looked at god as
sovereign
his sovereignty extends beyond the
universe if there's such a thing
god's sovereignty is boundless god is
accountable to no one
god does as he pleases and what let me
also add to that
everything god does is right by the way
psalm 145 verse 17
the lord is righteous in all his ways
and
holy in all his works god cannot do
wrong
god does not do wrong deuteronomy
chapter 32 verse 4
he is a god of truth and without
iniquity
that's why jesus could say in john 15 25
but this cometh to pass that the world
might the word might be fulfilled
that is written in their law they hated
me without a cause
no one ever has a cause a just cause to
be angry with god even though we always
get angry with him
no one has a just defensible cause to be
angry with god because god
does no wrong we go back to uh daniel 5
19 looking at nebuchadnezzar and his
sovereignty
whom he would he slew
nebuchadnezzar was a despot he was a
tyrant
as many oriental leaders were back then
he killed you if you wanted to he left
your life if you wanted to
whom he would he set up whom he would
he put down that's sovereignty
but we looked at sovereignty on god's
level
and sovereignty on the level of a
created being
now let's see something very interesting
we should give us courage and strength
as we live through these uncertain times
particularly in the united states
let us go to daniel chapter 2.
daniel is explaining a dream that
nebuchadnezzar had we've just been
talking about him
so let's go confront him daniel 2
you read verse 36 daniel explains the
details of the dream
this is the dream and we'll tell the
interpretation thereof before the king
verse 37 thou o king are the king of
kings
for the god of heaven have given thee a
kingdom
power and strength and glory
and wheresoever the children of men
dwell the beasts of the field
and the fouls of the heaven have fee
given into thy hand
and hath made the ruler over them all
thou art this head of gold
what is the bible saying god chose and
decided
that nebuchadnezzar would be the king of
babylon
of course for a certain period of time
which means
nebuchadnezzar's earthly sovereignty was
under the control of god
let me say that again no one controls
god's sovereignty
no one can limit the sovereignty of god
god
limits the so-called sovereignty of
sovereignty
of human beings nebuchadnezzar as we
would see it
was a sovereign
despot his power was absolute at an
earthly level
but it was god that allowed him to rule
for reasons best known to god
and god is not obligated to explain all
his doings to us this is where many of
us
fall we need to learn to trust god
because he knows what he's doing
when you go to the dentist or the doctor
i'm sure you don't question the person's
academic credentials
you accept the fact that the dentist
knows what he or she is doing
my dentist is a man let's use him so
when he tells me lean back i lean back
i don't ask why when he tells me open
your mouth and i'm sitting there like a
great fish with my mouth open
i don't ask him why i just open my when
he says bite down i bite down
when he says spit i spit when he says
open i open
when he says gargle i gargle why he's a
dentist
now if i took my car to the mechanic and
he told me open your mouth
then he would have a problem with me
he's a mechanic not a dentist
god when god says remember the sabbath
day keep it holy
we do it because he said so
god said so and god does not have to
give us the details as to why
he tells us obey me and we obey him
because god has given
us sufficient evidence of his love in
creation of course
and in the gift of jesus christ
nebuchadnezzar exercised
an earthly sovereignty now let's see
what the heavenly sovereignty
can do to the earthly sovereignty as we
continue rewriting the script let me
pray again father
speak through me i pray restrain me also
i ask in jesus name
amen nebuchadnezzar
set up an image daniel 3.
all people should buy all people nation
language first fourth then and herald
cried aloud
verse 4 of daniel 3 to you it is
commanded or people
nations and languages it is commanded
who gave the command
not a committee nebuchadnezzar how do we
know that
verse 10 thou o king has made a decree
that every man that shall hear the sound
of the cornet flute
harp sac but saltery and dulcimer and
all kinds of music
shall fall down and worship the golden
image and whoso falleth not down and
worship him that he should be cast into
the midst of a burning fiery furnace
you said that nebuchadnezzar as they
were complaining about the three men who
did not bow
this was nebuchadnezzar's command bow to
this image
we know shadrach meshach and abednego
who might prefer to call hananiah
michelle azariah because those hebrew
names attach them to god
shadrach meshach and abednego attached
them to
babylonian gods in so far as those three
names are understood
they refused to bow we know what
happened they were cast into the fire
the mechanizer said i see through four
men loose walk in the midst of the fire
and they have no hurt and the fourth of
the form is like the son of god
in verse 28 i want you to listen to what
nebuchadnezzar said
the beginning has spake and said them
blessed be the god of
shadrach meshach and abednego
who have sent his angel and delivered
his servants
that trusted in him and
have changed the king's word
when nebuchadnezzar chose the diet for
those hebrew captives
and daniel hananiah michelle azariah
decided not to eat it
the chief of the eunuchs was scared to
death
verse 9 of daniel 1 now god had brought
daniel into favor and tender love with
the prince of the eunuchs verse 10
and the prince of the eunuch said unto
daniel i fear the lord my king
which hath appointed your meat and your
drink for why should he see your faces
worse liking
than the faces of the children which are
of your sort then shall he make me
endanger my head to the king what he was
saying is this
if you don't eat this food my head will
be cut off this
is nebuchadnezzar people were scared of
him
now this same nebuchadnezzar in verse 28
of daniel 3 when the three hebrew boys
were miraculously
saved from flames he said blessed be the
god
of shadrach meshach and abednego who
have sent his angel
and delivered his servants that trusted
in him and have
changed the king's word i was subject
re-writing the script nebuchadnezzar's
script
for hananiah mishael and azariah was
death by fire that was his script
the most powerful man on the earth back
then
what do i mean the most powerful man on
the earth we're talking about the world
of the bible
when paul says in colossians 1 23 the
gospel was preached to every creature
under heaven
he did not have japan in mind or tierra
del fuego or the falklands or puerto
rico
he was talking about the world of the
bible are you with me of course
before christ come there will be a
worldwide fulfillment
of this gospel going to every creature
under heaven we're talking about the
world of the bible
nebuchadnezzar was the most powerful
being
he made a decree and god
changed it
this ought to bring you comfort why
there may be people who have certain
designs on your life
on your job on your children on your
influence
on your character whatever as a child of
god you need the assurance that you
serve a god who can change the word of
an earthly despot
here in the united states we see an
attempt to change the constitution
i think his name is michael flynn who
served a couple days in
president trump's cabinet he was
recently pardoned
he recommended to the president that he
suspend the constitution and declare
martial law
now this is not a political statement
i'm not a politician i'm simply saying
we're dealing with the most powerful man
on earth
the president of united states is
recognized as the most powerful
man on earth and i say on earth but he
is under the control of the sovereign of
the universe
proverbs 21 verse 1 keep this verse with
you when you think
that a system in the united states or
anywhere else is against you and that
there is no hope for you
proverbs 21 1 our subject re-writing the
script
i love that verse very much the king's
heart
is in the hand of the lord
nebuchadnezzar's heart was in god's
hands
as the rivers of water he turneth it
with us so
ever he will that's why our focus must
not be
on a political party or social movement
it has to be
on god because
god has final say there is nothing that
happens on this earth
or anywhere in the universe where god
does not exercise command
or permission
rewriting the script the script for
hananiah
mishael and azariah was death by
fire god changed that writing and
nebuchadnezzar confessed
he have changed the king's word
let's take a look at the sovereign of
the universe changing the script again
please believe your life is in the hand
of god
not in the hand of a secular leader
your life is in the hand of god
daniel 6 nebuchadnezzar is gone
darius is now the king babylon is gone
the middle persians are in control
darius is the king
darius makes a decorative for 30 days
all people should pray to him
daniel wouldn't do it now remember the
laws of the medes and the persians alter
not
verse 8 verse 9 of daniel 6.
so when the the the princes and the
rulers told darius
sign establish the decree sign the
writings
that it be changed not according to the
law of the medes and the persians
which altered if not verse 9 says that
darius established the decree he signed
the writing
verse 16 then the king commanded and
they brought daniel and cast him into
the den of lions
now the king spake and said to daniel
thy god whom thou serve us continually
he will deliver thee my decree is you
have to go to the lion's den
that the script for daniel was death by
con being consumed by wild ravenous
beasts
verse 17 of daniel 6 and a stone was
brought and laid upon the mouth of the
den
and the king sealed it with his own
signet
and with the sickness of his lords that
the purpose
might not be changed concerning daniel
all the powers on earth symbolized by
darius
the head of the most powerful nation in
the world of the bible
daniel must not escape what we have
decided for him
must not change the king signed it with
the sale
all his lords signed with their sales
that the purpose
might not change concerning daniel but
there's a god in heaven watching
darius had limited sovereignty he knew
not
that he was in the control of the
sovereign of the universe
and so the bible says the king went to
his palace verse 18 and passed the night
fasting
neither instruments of music brought
before him and his sleep went from him
early in the morning he rose went in
haste to the den of lions and when he
came to
the end he cried with a lamentable voice
to daniel and said oh daniel
the king spake and said to daniel oh
daniel is thy god whom thou serve us
continually
able to deliver thee from the lions
verse 21 then said daniel under the king
o king live forever
listen carefully my god have sent his
angel
and have shut the lion's mouth
that they have not hurt me
for as much as before him innocency was
found in me
and also before the o king have i done
no hurt daniel 6
the decree of darius was daniel should
be consumed by white lions
darius was sovereign god
who overrules our plans and propositions
god changed the script signed by
darius and decided daniel should live my
listening friends
your first concern cannot be who runs
the government
your first concern must be what is my
relationship
with the one who runs the universe and
this is particularly critical
in these last days in which we live a
friend of mine sent me a text
today earlier today and he briefly
mentioned the coveted 19 crisis and he
said
this is mild concerning what is to come
and he's not a believer he's not
believing god at all
he said this is mild concerning that
which is
i wrote back and said you sound
prophetic he said no not prophetic
pragmatic
and i left it at that but he was right
this is mild concerning what is to come
the the believer the child of god
as he or she and educated by prophecy
sees what's coming
that person should strengthen his or her
grip
on the right hand of god
because it is with the sovereign of the
universe
where our hope lies and our salvation
my brothers and my sisters
god has sovereignty
when jesus was in the boat in the storm
he was sleeping the disciples were
panicking trying to remove the water
from the boat
jesus rose rebuked the wind said unto
the sea peace be still
the wind ceased it was a great calm
christ rested
in his father's care and his father's
love
and his father's word and the word
distilled the sea was the power of god
christ rested in his father's care
his father's love his father's word what
am i saying to you
in these troubling trying and
troublesome times
in which you and i live we must place
our feet
on the solid rock of the sovereign of
the universe and that is god
because god knows the end from the
beginning god sets up kings
and puts them down daniel 2 21
he changes the times and the seasons he
removeth kings
and set it up kings god is
in overall control of what is happening
in the united states
and the world you and i we wear our
masks
or maybe you don't we do what we need to
do to stay free from this virus
we look at the restrictions placed on
various nations things are getting
fairly severe here in california
lockdowns are becoming tight in europe
we don't know what will happen in six
months
will this vaccine work is it truly for
curing disease or making money we have
no clue
because we have no access to the rooms
where decisions are made but god knows
what's going on at the highest
level of power at the highest
levels of power god knows because he is
the one
controlling events for his personal
glory and for the vindication of his
name and for the blessing of the entire
universe
your child of god should keep his or her
hand
in the hand of god the sovereign of the
universe
and as we read in proverbs 21 1 the
king's heart is in the hand
of the lord president trump's heart is
in the hand of god
his mind is in the hand of god vladimir
putin's mind is in the hand of god
angela merkel's mind is in the hand of
god boris johnson's
mind is in the heart of is in the hand
of god god has
final say and overall control as he
allows events to develop
according to his will while you and i do
not know the details of those wills
we do not know what's going on we know
that god
will stand behind his people as god
changed the writing for daniel
in the lands then as god changed the
writing
for the three hebrew boys god re-wrote
the script
the script was written by an earthly
sovereign and the universal sovereign
changed the script he rewrote it
there was nothing the beginning could do
nothing darius as a matter of fact
nebuchadnezzar eventually became
converted as a result of the
demonstration of god's sovereignty in
the lives of daniel through hebrew boys
and of course daniel again in
interpreting the dream and the life that
he lived
re-writing the script satan
has a script for your life here is it
the thief cometh not but for the steel
to kill and to destroy that's the
devil's script
i am come that they might have life
that they is you and they might have it
more abundantly the devil script is the
thief cometh not
but for to steal to kill and to destroy
god rewrites it i am come that they
might have life
now both scripts cannot operate in
a person's life at the same time
let me say it again slowly both scripts
cannot operate in a believer's life at
the same time
it is either the devil's script or the
script of god
and we've seen the power of god to
change
the script of an earthly sovereign the
devil's intention for your life
is chaos disorder anarchy and ruined
yes accessorized by so-called successes
god's script for you
i am come that you might have life
and that you might have it more
abundantly
i'll close by presenting to you a god
who is in absolute control
of what happens in the world and the
universe unless the events page 243
paragraph four ella white writes these
interesting words
the same destructive power exercised by
holy angels when god permits
or commands will be exercised by evil
angels when god permits
you must understand that god commands or
permits either way
god is in final absolute control of what
is happening
and god has allowed the constitutional
crisis the
the electoral crisis in this country he
has allowed it
for reasons attached to his glory and
the purification of his church
when you and i cannot understand what's
happening
we trust god when three armies came
against jehoshaphat
ii chronicles chapter 20 reading from
verse 1
down to verse 12 he ends a prayer this
way oh our god will thou not judge them
for we have no might against this great
company that cometh against us
neither know we what to do but our eyes
are upon thee
and in this uncertain world keep your
eye
on god isaiah 45 22 look unto me
and be saved all the ends of the earth
look to me
how do we look at god through his word
studied and obeyed our title tonight
re-writing the script the script for
your life
as the devil will write it is
destruction
ultimate destruction the script for your
life as
god has written it is a blessed life
that begins now and continues in the
life to come
uninterruptedly i urge you
as your brother in christ as the one
privileged to deliver this message
take your stand with the sovereign
of the universe he knows what's best
he knows what will happen tomorrow he
has all the forces against you
under control let me say it again all
the forces against you are under control
but remember the words of darius in
daniel 6
verse 20 and the words of shadrach
meshach bendigo in daniel 3
when nebuchadnezzar threatened to burn
them they said
if it be so our god whom we serve
is able to deliver us when darius
being broken-hearted he would lose
daniel he said is thy god
whom thou serve us continually
so while god is suffering god is
all-powerful
when we get next to god it simply means
we are willing to serve god
obey god and follow god's will
god delivers those who obey him
and serve him let me say it again god
delivers those
who obey him who serve him let god
re-write whatever script the devil has
written for your life
let god rewrite it how is god going to
do that
give your life to god and how do you do
that
give it you simply say lord i cannot
save myself i need a savior
i give you my life if you're unable to
say that
simply say lord i do not know how to
give you my life
take it take it doesn't mean kill me it
means
come and take possession of my mind i do
not know how to give it
i ask you now take my life take control
sit on the throne of my heart
and direct me rewriting the script
let god change whatever the devil has in
mind for you
he did it with nebuchadnezzar he did it
with darius
he does it with every leader on earth as
god sees fit
because our god is in ultimate and final
control
when all this controversy comes to a
climax
every initial bow and every tongue shall
confess
that jesus christ is lord to the glory
of god the father let's pray father in
heaven we thank you for your word
we thank you great god for its clarity
it's directness
and its individual touch help us there
god
help us to ally ourselves
with the sovereign of the universe
that's you
through jesus christ let us not live our
lives in fear of what will happen
in this country or any other country let
us understand
that when the life is in the hands of
god it becomes god's
moral responsibility to take care of
that life
that's given to him help us to make that
wise
choice their god to stand with the
sovereign of the universe
who can change any plans rewrite any
script
the enemy may have for our lives bless
those who listened
a double blessing on the children a
sweet blessing and all guests who tuned
in
hear this humble prayer father when you
come save us because it's your will to
do that
and we have cooperated with your will in
jesus name i pray
amen